[Music]
having sort of an intimacy or an
understanding of violence and
understanding uh having some real sort
of uh fluency in that and and and real
experience in that
um do you think that that is necessary
in terms of being sort of a confident
and um humble and uh ford moving no no i
i i you know it certainly could play a
factor in
for people like mark and myself in our
lives
um but hardship i i just look at it like
hardship we can there's so many people
that he's served in the communities he
served and certainly i've served in in
the fire department
uh where you know they're
they're conditioned unfortunately
by circumstance you know in the
socioeconomic situation that they're in
but
there's so much beauty that that sprouts
from hardship too
it's you know you've got to be able to
take the lessons
that life has thrust upon you
or or your work is thrust upon you and
grow and learn from that
and and take the opportunity to learn
from failure
i've i've worked in organizations where
you know
unfortunately sometimes the ego um
overrides a sense of
uh higher duty where oh
you know this this person or these group
of people made this mistake right
and it's and it's serious and it's
significant
um
and
without
without a culture like the military
where i've had whereas if you make
mistakes in the military that goes in an
after-action report that is for everyone
to learn from so nobody else makes that
same mistake
and the civilian world is just a little
bit different
um
i mean it's we don't have to get too
deep into you know unions and all this
other stuff but we have to be able to
say look this person made this mistake
we want him to be better we want
everyone around him or her to be better
and we want this organization to grow
from that and i think culturally from
from my from my perspective we're
changing we're slowly growing out of
that we're we're bound to make mistakes
right that's that's also because our
jobs are difficult there's a lot of
hardship hardships in our jobs right um
and there's there's certain things
you're going to be good at and there's
certain things that you're just going to
be thrust into a situation where you're
going to have to figure it out you're
just going to have to navigate it and
make the best judgment you possibly can
because you've never been on a call like
this you've never been in a situation
like this
and
you you know you're thinking about the
safety of everyone while all this is
going on
and then you take that home right
there's just certain things that are
heavy
or heavier um
and we all process things differently
but um that adds to the element of
hardship well again you know take pause
and you know mark was talking about
being mindful is like how
did this affect our performance how did
this affect my crew individually
um how do we navigate this now how do we
grow from this hey
i can appreciate failure like i can i
have failed enough in my life where it's
like hey let's look at like what went
wrong and when did it start to go wrong
as opposed to you know the salem witch
trails let's burn everybody down
so that's that's kind of my my take on
um
violence versus hardship right right
yeah i think the bigger piece is that
the the individual's ability resilience
to recover right are you going to go in
the tank
or
are you going to get back up off the
floor
right that's the challenge uh
that you know anytime you're working
with folks or you're mentoring them
uh
there's there's a balance between
patting them on the ass and then kicking
them in the ass you gotta push people
my biggest push as i as i work with with
people is it's really a
different training that i'm putting on
and they're attending but it's it's
really a
leadership development disguised as
hostage rescue got it but really
everything is at the core it's about
leadership got it
um
so
you know i've been married my wife uh
we've married about seven years
and this is a woman that's changed my
life selfless
it's always about doing for others
and you know i subscribed to that along
the way especially at work i was more
than happy to stick my neck out for
people and take care of my team members
and whatever it took
but i really wasn't honest about who i
was as a man
not making the best decisions along the
way not being mentally present uh
sometimes not being physically present
and there was a selfish side to me that
uh that i justified my absence because
i'm out doing the lord's work so to
speak
but but uh
over time i started to realize you know
what there's a level of commitment in my
personal life
not with my friends you know guys you
know how that works with your buddies
that's a different connection but but
really
connecting to somebody and committing to
you know being not only responsible for
yourself but responsible for them
and and and really
leading
as a father right that uh
that's the second chance that i've been
given so that is
it's awesome that's awesome man does
that make sense it does make sense it
does make sense when you talk about you
know getting a little bit of time also
for yourself and taking care of yourself
sneaking that rest in i know you you
know you did just get back from this uh
trip and i know that you know when i'm
talking to trace
you you know she sort of explained it
and you've kind of explained it that
you know sometimes you like you you're
not a guy like this [ __ ] ain't
going to the barbados and like drinking
a drink with like a [ __ ] umbrella
like when you go on a trip it's like
like that you there's still this
i don't know what the word is that the
animal in you or the monster in you
whatever it is and i feel like is that
what these sort of
vacations i don't even know
these these trips that you go like what
what are they and like what do they do
for you well my lifelong dream i just
went to tanzania and it was a walking
safari so there's only a couple um
you know companies out in uh in the
serengeti that allow you to walk across
the serengeti with guides so you walk
with a park ranger by law and then you
walk through a guy who's been ch who's
been trained by the state they're both
carrying rifles
and my buddy uh and myself and his wife
um we're gonna go on this hundred mile
walking tour and every night you camping
little tents
um but um no roads you do have some
support with the
you know the the safari uh company that
basically sets up camp for you at
certain locations but you're in it
you're
you're you're in this place that
um just demands respect and you're
on this
amazing parcel of land that's incredibly
beautiful
but these massive creatures that are
there um
you know that are so powerful
um just put you in awe and you're you're
there on their terms you're a guest
so to have those experiences amongst the
lions hyenas elephants and buffalo and
uh you know it was it was incredible you
learn a lot about animal behavior you
learn how to navigate the land with the
guides
take paws
take a break observe animal behavior
get as close as you can
so we're always walking up wind and
and then from there we went to zanzibar
and spearfished in the deep blue ocean
and you know you you're around big
creatures there too and
it's calculated risk but you know you
also have to understand that if you're
comfortable in those environments and
you put the trust in yourself and the
people that are around you you're going
to have an amazing time right so it's
just it's just a beautiful experience i
love it are you are you buying that
response
i don't know what do you think man
well i think you know
knowing kevin it's it's it is about the
risk it's about
seeking that risk
it's about managing
fear right and
it's a test
i mean all those things may be true and
it was
eloquently put yeah the reality is
i mean what'd you do before that
did you take a swim somewhere oh yeah i
swam alcatraz you swam alcatraz that's
right
where all the sharks
again
it's calculated
and what is that what what leads you to
swim alcatraz well
a buddy of mine called me from the seal
teams he said hey
there's a family that has
really supported different veteran
organizations
the family would love to swim alcatraz
would you mind swimming it with them
we'll have a few guys from the teams to
support them this is something that they
want to do this was our way of of
supporting them and and saying thank you
it it just comedy it sometimes because
you it's murky it's choppy it's you know
it's cold water and you're like you know
who's there yeah yeah yeah um
and you run the gauntlet so to speak and
then there were about 12 sea lions that
started to swim around us for about 10
minutes is that better or you're like i
mean though i mean the sharks will eat
the sea lions right they're like they're
left no the sea lions are laughing at us
oh really yeah yeah you can [ __ ] out
here
you slow awkward whatever you are right
yeah yeah um but no it was in the end it
was it's you know you you're you have a
feeling of exhilaration when you're done
and uh
and then you know just for the for the
sake of that family and everything that
they've committed to these veterans
organizations it was again it's just a
big thank you for them yeah you know
yeah yeah that was good you do uh what
do you do what do you do to unwind you
you got any
uh you know what i'm the i'm the guy if
i'm gonna get away i'm to i'm going to
go to wherever and i'm going to sit by
the pool
uh and chill out i stopped drinking
about a year and a half ago
that's really not uh i'm not sitting
around drinking but
for
for a guy like me you know the hamsters
always tearing up yeah you know what i
mean it's it's always churning so
for me
i had a lot of anxiety because my brain
was always you know what's the next
thing what's the next thing uh
you know constant problem solving and
trying to work for something
you know what else is out there to do uh
within the given field but
you know for me just really slowing down
slowing down
and just be honest with you john just
spending more time with the family
that's the beauty of
what's happened you know last couple
years it's it's really
brought people back home
and uh
hopefully readjusted their priorities be
there for your family it is number your
number one priority uh
and make that sacrifice and quit making
excuses for your [ __ ]
then you become a [ __ ] man that's it
and then
you start to look at things a lot
different and you start enjoying your
life um
absent that you know what's the point
what are you doing what are you doing
i got a question for you john please man
it goes back to a conversation we had
many years ago
when you talked about your training when
you went to moscow
and you you studied uh performance art
under a certain style
you'd come back to the united states
and one of your mentors and one of your
teachers when we when we talk about
hardship when we talk about sacrifice
you know warned you very early on in
your career like be careful of how much
you give to your character
right because where's john bernthal in
the end of your this long career is
stripping away at you each
each commitment you make to another
human being right and
and
certainly we've talked about the
complexities of of of our jobs and and
what we're reserving for when we come
home is like how do you navigate that
you know there was a time i think
especially after we worked together uh
you know in england on fury yeah i just
went back to england to promote this new
movie and it was crazy man just just
even like kind of like being there i i
you know it's
i think for a while i started to worry
about how
how much i was going in and and and sort
of would i'd be able to really be
present there for my family and my
friends and my life when it was over and
how
you know who am i am i am i staying in
this one
but but i've come to this conclusion man
that i'm never not gonna work that way
that you know the the the bottom line is
that i'm i'm putting you know my kids
names on
the the the job that i'm doing and and
this job is taking me away from my kids
so i'm going to go in as fully there's
no stone i'm going to leave unturned i'm
never going to make
you know
nothing lazy like if there's work to do
go [ __ ] do it 100
and so i'm going to work that way but
what i've come to sort of find is that
you know i get to meet these [ __ ]
amazing people and i get to like learn
these unbelievable skills and and look i
love actors and i love the business but
it's the it's the folks that i get to
meet in in those worlds and you walk
away with these french i mean look man
we've we've been friends now for it's
been a long time man and like you know i
trust you you know like i know who you
are i know who your family is like and i
look again like in baltimore these
relationships that i made these the the
communities that i got to go and the
experiences that i got to have um
yeah man they'd like really really
[ __ ] changed me um and so
and the first thing i said to you guys
when i started there's a cost you know i
was not you know i missed a couple jiu
jitsu tournaments you know missed a
whole heck of a lot of games it's a lot
of nights you know my wife is driving
everybody around you know and and and
and doing all the cooking and all the
cleaning and that's wearing on her like
i get that there's the heavy [ __ ]
lifting so i can go out there and you
know be mr pretend [ __ ] you know but
the the the the the bottom line is j i
think just as long as you you kind of
keep those in mind the whole time you
never lose sight of the truth of what's
actually going on
you know when you're when you're in a
certain business like even yours man
you're you're gone you know you got to
film you got this project you're gone
and and there's such a balance
uh that that has to happen
you know and then at the end of the day
you provide the best foundation for your
kids and then they walk out the door and
then you just uh you know
[Music]
pray if you will right there's a duality
right it's like there's a mindset you
need to have at work
that you need to shift away from so that
you can be at home and you could be that
dad and you could be that husband and be
president be aware and pour that energy
because
it's shifting gears when you go back to
work it's like all right i
those things do not line up
right i've got to be this other
this other being right now for the sake
for the sake of everyone around you
and the community as well
[Music]
foreign